hello and welcome to this video playing
PT Capri shouldn t be at the Olympiad
he's from Cyprus so he should be the
best player of Cyprus ok I'm not not
quite up to date and what's happening
there it what is that check check it
might be business on the dark squares
like a queen tonight be five and stuff
and but ok so might be five is well I
have some ideas myself here I can also
just go Queen to e7 that is not bad or
something similar like 25 he cannot
castle this is kind of a kind of
important but might be five is a very
annoying move
hmm yeah go for technical play or not it
feels a bit weird to do that but it took
like a 6 and 9 p-5 is somebody annoying
93 no okay this is a very unique
decision brilliant
but um
keep it simple and this game is kind of
important because if I win it I'm
crossing the 2500 again that always
feels cool I know this is kind of mine
Jack yeah how do you call its kind of my
sound to sound barrier what's what's
what's the name if I can get over that
it's really really great okay so yeah
let's use this and this is covered this
is covered hmm that was very stupid I
was just thinking it's Hanks but it
doesn't okay I'm 95 blunders stuff
either how how stupid can you play okay
I'm just going back very strange anyway
it's still very nice the missing f porn
is also a problem for him in terms of in
terms of the e5 square some b6 Bishop 86
seems okay
yeah nine Central series stupid you
night here and back and stuff with okay
he might have night f7 something like
that yeah maybe let's let's just cover
this it looks like a decent move anyway
and now we should a six I guess yeah so
c-5m just will be eight you can also try
not to see for to trade stuff not sure
how good this is technically speaking
and it's going to be 8l boobie 8 of
light beat get all of that diagonal
yahoo takes snide c5 so probably take
with this looks a bit strange with the
look on ba but i wanted to get out of
the diagonal so so night sea floor let's
solidify that let's do this get rid of
that bloody night down ok so what to do
95 probably still a pretty good square
there's no need to trade and Knight to
c4 is still going to be somewhat
annoying and maybe Knight f3 is this
idea i 75 it's not that much of a
problem I hope
f5 and d5 that would be nice to play
kindle and so already over the situation
I would know I get our Father just
completely blocking his bishop
something like rook to see three and
then try to trade the the Knights like
we would get at the be three Pawn okay
he loves me that I wonder I don't really
see a tech deck so I'm going in here
check okay here yet is the desperate
desperation tactic was just a matter of
time until it until it hit so night f7
yeah it's not you will check 95 problem
check I am Bishop g5 moment might say
snow night anymore time warning so and
it's group these six shoot this this
this it's not easy at all shoot
and then he's got a ton of chicks time
maybe no it's going to draw jack aah
chak chak chak that's a shame check our
general game through I am such an idiot
and that should never happen after this
opening I mean okay I played in a very
technical way but did it it's until it's
totally winning of course like so since
ndm missus is just totally winning I
just have to play it correctly yeah I
missed one idea night 85 that the
computer immediately points out and this
is very strong for night see form but
okay that doesn't really matter what i
did is totally ok I mean it wasn't the
the best measure this is just
desperation I just have to be more
precisely and the game's over so night
I've 7hx me true check check it is
little it is still a win I can't go to F
I can go to G 4chan just sorry this I
just didn't think about that I can go
here check like this okay I can just go
back and I'm still winning because i
have i have an attack here and I look f
83 oopsy to end stuff this is minus five
so I agreed to a draw in a winning
position it's also cool check check haha
oh it was very easy to get to 2500 here
after you play Bishop g5 in the opening
okay well I need a break thanks for
watching